after starting 3 out of 4 the Mavericks
with misfires their last three times
down the school
Eurostat into the lap let's SPT at his
best
Westbrook birthday dance little bit
euro-step is an impact in their only win
in round 1 at 102.3 bound triple doubles
of his life Josh Huestis cook 3 is the
lip touch off the basket and the Thunder
makes it a one-point game
clean those things up on pole dance the
both teams George loved the kick from
his district rain
tough shot got the rebound George will
drive the double-team the Thunder with
its largest lead in the game at 6 points
all-time leader in assists
[Music]
[Applause]
and finished off to the little
rattlesnake jam yeah with the top of his
head into Jeremy grants chin they both
go down Brent's gonna scream for George
and then the lob pass
Roberson underneath the finish in the
game old for 5-3
the ball games of force the Mavericks
they have a lot of dribbling not a whole
lot of movement towards with the steal
just two assists in the game the
straightaway trail George melanin
second round draft pick in 2015 d-league
allstar last season's come step of the
way from Savitsky a scores
let's get just backs up styling outside
two three filled towel trying to keep it
alive Matthews saves it we've got the
Rockefeller Jersey on his dirk nowitzki
only the floor now do you think they
know each other
[Applause]
thirty points out of the starting
backcourt more than average tonight sets
his feet draws charge look at that
saw that a little daylight in that TT
and it goes right
[Music]
[Applause]
that's nasty eight rebounds 7 assists
three this is why I say assassin you
know I mean he doesn't make much of